alrighty folks so you may have noticed
that hollywood continues to drift away
from the rest of the country they are
just going to produce now stuff
that is directed at your politics and
they're going to talk about how
wonderful they are well today
we're going to go over some of the most
divisive movies splitting the critics
and the audience straight down the
center cause the audience is like you
and the critics are a bunch of elitists
who really don't like you this is why
you should head over to dailywire.com
subscribe okay so let us jump right in
so
we have a list here of a bunch of movies
that the critics absolutely love
and that audiences did not because the
fact remains that the critics are
completely out of touch with american
audiences they are
all drawn from the same substrata of
american life these are all people who
went to ivy league colleges and who
speak the vocabulary
and so all of their movie viewing is
through this lens and so they understand
all the politics of the films that they
are being asked to cover we're also
going to be talking about some of these
movies where the critics absolutely
hated it but the audience loves it and
again
it very often comes down to a divide in
values by the way a great example of a
of a movie where critics hated it but
the audience really liked it
hillbillyology which we've talked about
in the past again that was all about the
left despising the book
and feeling that people who are trump
voters simply should not be understood
so any film made about those people
must inherently be a very very bad film
okay so let's jump into some of these
big
divides let's start with captain marvel
so on tomato meter has a 79 positive
review the audience score for this thing
is like 46
now i'll be honest with you i didn't
hate captain marvel i didn't think it
was like awful
but it is pretty obvious that this
divide is mainly over the quote unquote
importance
of captain marvel every time there is a
superhero film
that features a quote-unquote victimized
group the media just go crazy over it
for example
even movies i like they do this wonder
woman a movie i enjoyed this became the
most important statement on female
empowerment ever in the history of the
world
patty jenkins had direct it was like
citizen kane is the greatest
they did the same thing with captain
marvel which is a significantly worse
movie than wonder woman wonder woman is
actually a pretty good movie
captain marvel is kind of drecky it's
just like me
she's an unlikable character brie larson
is not charming in any way her character
is radically uninteresting because
she's magical right because she can
literally do anything she has no limits
on her powers the critics love this of
course and they also love these subtle
messagings there's the not so subtle
messaging which is
women power woo in fact there's a scene
in this movie
in which captain marvel basically
physically abuses
a normal man for telling her to smile
and the critic's like oh that's that's
amazing that's amazing
so let me just get this straight if a
guy says something sexist the proper
answer is physical violence done by
somebody of superior physical force
i feel like that could lead to some bad
things in any case here is a sample
critic review monique jones of shadow
and act
the skrulls also provide the film with a
chance to inject a subtle dig
at today's politics surrounding
immigration whereas these skrulls were
painted
as an invasive species by the kree it
turns out the kree are the ones who want
to build
walls and turn families into refugees
the switcheroo should give the audience
a moment of reflection since in our
political realm the president of the
united states
unfairly paints immigrants and refugees
as violent invaders from bleep hole
countries
overall captain marvel is a film you
should be proud to let your children
watch oh well it's uh and the audience
meanwhile it's like
they weren't like we hate it it was like
20 on rotten tomatoes they're like
it's not really good movie number two
where you see a vast gap between
the critics and the audience and this
one is one of my personal bugaboos
star wars the last jedi absolute crap
whereas captain marvel is like a
passable piece
of b-minus entertainment star wars the
last jedi takes all of your childhood
memories and just wrecks them
so i had problems with the force awakens
the last jedi is even worse it takes
luke
and turns him into a whiny basically
sitting around
on a planet doing nothing and milking
aliens all day
that's the entire plot of the film
meanwhile we have a secondary plot about
class warfare and animal rights
on some random gambling island that has
nothing to do with anything and we have
a third plot a tertiary plot
in which a space maneuver is used that
completely destroys
all space battles ever in the star wars
universe right i mean like if you could
do the holdo
maneuver in any space battle there is no
death star battle
in star wars episodes four or star wars
episode six you just aim an x-wing at
the center of the death star and you're
done right
that's pretty much the whole thing in
any case it's a dumb movie it's a bad
movie it's like a legit bad movie the
last jedi and it's that doesn't mean
it's not beautifully shot it is
beautifully shot
and there's one good lightsaber battle
and that's pretty much all i have to say
for last jedi i'm not the only one
saying this right
like everyone who watched the last jedi
in the audience like this is not a good
movie this is a very bad movie
and yet the critics loved the movie and
more importantly the critics were very
very angry at the audience for not
liking the movie it was not just that
the critics liked the movie
because it broke stereotypical molds and
all this kind of stuff and it brought in
characters like rose that nobody has
ever cared about like
rose is just a bad guy my favorite is
like yeah the audience hates rose
because she's female well the artist is
pretty cool with princess leia who's
like
maybe the most central figure in all of
the star wars canon in the original
three films right the entire plot is
built around saving princess leia in one
the entire plot is built around princess
leia and han solo
in two and then in three princess leia
and luke's relationship comes to the
four
so somehow everybody was okay with
princess leia it's just we don't like
rose because she's unbelievably boring
and why are we wasting time on her but
then it was like oh you're sexist
because you don't like rose right
this is where you got the toxic fandom
crap or it's like oh if you don't like a
piece of entertainment
you're going to attribute it to the evil
trump voting nature of your audience or
some such nonsense
i'm sorry that the last jedi is bad it's
just not a good movie
i mean tough okay the media meanwhile
were like yeah this is great
it's it's just it's great no it was it
was not it was not
okay passengers was another one of these
movies that the critics
wildly over politicized so there is a
chris pratt
backlash that has happened over the last
few years because chris pratt of course
is a conservative and so people in the
media will not allow chris pratt to
have a critically acclaimed film they
just won't allow it to happen because
he's not overly conservative he goes to
a church and because he goes to a church
this means he's a conservative that's
just the way that it works in hollywood
in hollywood the way that they think of
jesus is as jesus a guy who does their
gardening because everyone named jesus
in hollywood
is considered a person who does your
gardening because everybody in hollywood
is tacitly racist against latinos i'm
not kidding about that that's an actual
thing
yeah i live in hollywood and i used to
live in hollywood anyway
and um this is why you see so many
hollywood people who are like yeah you
know
illegal immigration is good because i
need a guard like people will say that
kind of stuff okay in any case
passengers is not a bad movie passengers
is an okay movie
it is not a bad movie it's about
jennifer lawrence and chris pratt and
they are traveling
through space and it's sort of the slow
romance it was pitched to sort of an
action film so part of the problem is
that it was pitched badly
but the film is really about he wakes up
early on this trans
galactic journey and he's the only
person who's woken up
and so he decides that he's going to
wake somebody else up because otherwise
he's basically going to commit suicide
so he wakes her up she falls in love
with him
and then gets over it and not to be a
spoiler but this movie came out in 2016.
they end up together uh they don't end
up living all the way to the ship
reaching its destination but they end up
like having
making sure that the ship actually runs
the way it's supposed to run is that it
doesn't fall apart and they save
everybody who's on the ship
because the ship is having all sorts of
technical malfunctions this was
considered for some reason like a rape
culture movie that's what
team vogue said brianna weiss said
throughout the lead-up to the movie
trailers and previews frame gym in
aurora's situation it seemed like a
random act of fate in which both
characters wake up in a suspended time
space reality
however the companionship was a
deliberate non-consensual act done out
of one man's sheer desperation
loneliness obsession and longing okay
and that ends up as a
pretty major plot point in the film
right i mean jennifer lawrence at a
certain point
is informed that he woke her up
and this becomes sort of a major plot
point then the question is will she
forgive him
and i think people are just saying what
she did because for some reason being
continuously
rageful is is supposed to be a solution
in intergalactic space when the only
other person awake
within you know light years uh is is a
person who did something bad to you so
forgiveness is apparently bad
producer neil moore said there was a
weird thing that happened we'd done
numerous test screening
that were very encouraging everything
was looking great 10 days before the
movie came out the first review came out
the reviewer said we were justifying
date rape and i was like what
i thought back to all the screenings we
had nobody ever thought that but it was
weird
one guy said it a lot of the media
picked up on it and became the mod for
the film carried i thought it was a
really unfair thing i think it's a
beautiful film i couldn't be more proud
of
there's no question that that is what
happened this thing became political
okay
another movie midway tomato meter has it
at 41
audience score has it at 92 percent it
is a perfectly
fine rope by numbers world war ii film
that does a good job of exploiting what
happened at the battle of the midway and
surrounding battles
i wouldn't say it's like an a plus film
i would say it's like a b film
okay but the critics absolutely despised
it and i think one of the reasons the
critics despised it is because it didn't
do this whole like
both sides were bad both sides were
terrible midway basically says no the
americans were good and the japanese
were kind of not good
in the battle of the midway which is
accurate you're allowed to portray
americans as heroes in world war ii for
goodness sake
but a lot of members of the media were
upset about that right according to
roxanna hadadi for
pajiba midway has all the other
components you would expect from a world
war ii movie like a wife left behind and
brief glimpses behind enemy
lines i was surprised actually by how
much screen time was given to the
japanese engineers of the war
and to the fact the film was dedicated
to both american and japanese soldiers
midway makes sure though that every
american has provided moments of heroism
while the japanese are mostly just there
is screaming mocking villains who juror
the american pilots
before they are killed but that too
feels like part of the political game
midway is playing
the idea the world was better back then
because of men like dick best men who
are straightforward in their whiteness
and their strictness and their
american-ness
oh so tiresome okay which brings us to
another
woke favorite ghostbusters like female
ghostbusters
so nobody ever saw the original
ghostbusters which is basically a male
buddy comedy and thought you know what
this would be a better movie with ladies
what we need
are our ladies in ghostbusters in
overtly male film i mean it's a very
male film the original ghostbusters
it's like bill murray and dana like come
on and then they're like you know what
if we made them all women
and made the film utterly unamusing what
if we did that and then we scolded
everyone who didn't like the film so
it has 74 on tomato meter the audience
score is 50
so naturally whenever people don't like
something the critics love it's because
the audience is not woke enough and
they're bad and they're terrible and
toxic fandom and all of that it is a bad
movie it is a not funny movie
puffy directed the movie i don't like
just like all of his movies i think that
bridesmaids is okay
it's all right in fact he's made a
couple of sort of off-brand movies he
made one of sandra bullock that was kind
of funny
but for some reason this one became like
the cause
celeb of the day that if you didn't like
those female go if you did not dictate
that this was like the greatest film in
human history
this is because you hated the ladies or
something sian brett one room with a
view
said getting to see four normal looking
women on screen of all shapes sizes and
colors is rare
let alone seeing them be action heroes
who save the day and ghostbusters isn't
preachy about it at all
it presents the fact that their women is
entirely normal which might be the most
revolutionary thing of all
now ghostbusters pretty preachy about it
snappy jokes kick-ass women a great
fight sequence all make ghostbusters a
fun as hell blockbuster which you don't
want to miss
yeah audiences found a tiresome their
right to find a tire summons tiresome
other movies that the critics absolutely
loved that the audience absolutely hated
cuties has a tomato meter score of 87
the audience scored is 15 and it led to
a mass drop off by people
on netflix like people were like we are
not going to patronize a service
that somehow thinks that distributing
films that lasciviously
show 11 year old girls twerking is a
good idea and by the way there's no
question that's what the film does
i have seen the film cuties i think i
know what the director was trying to do
she actually was attempting
to critique this but in the process of
critiquing this it was too sophisticated
for the audience in some ways and and i
think far beyond what it had to be in
order to make the critique
basically the idea was that in a world
without proper
role models uh in a secular france
without proper role models
uh you you end up trapped as a person
between
sort of the the sex-based internet
lifestyle
and the main character is a muslim girl
uh
and and a fundamentalist muslim
lifestyle that is also not compatible
with freedom so i think actually the
critique that it's making is sort of
michelle hollaback
critique and i think it's kind of right
but the problem is that the movie in
order to make the critique decides that
it is worthwhile to gaze longingly
at the posteriors of small children
which is just yeah
and the critics were very upset that
anybody would find fault with this
beth webb of empire magazine says cuties
is a thematically bold yet nuanced study
of displacement and duty that deserves
to be seen
as an auspicious and astute debut not
the source of scandal well i mean you
can see why people thought it was a
scandal honestly i think that netflix's
marketing did this film no favors
because they actively
promoted this as like a fun romp in
which
young pre-teen girls were being
portrayed as sex objects so
i'm i'm with the audience in other words
another movie in which the critics loved
it and the audience really did not this
would be sausage party
this entire thing is just a referendum
on how terrible religion
is and it ends with an orgy by food like
it's all simulated sex
rituals with involving food it's a bunch
of dick jokes basically
[Music]
my producers just forced me to re-watch
uh the orgy scene at the end of sausage
party so again the entire premise of the
film
is that it is a bunch of food items who
are thinking about whether they're going
to
get to heaven and then it turns out
there is no heaven because this is an
atheist film
about how heaven doesn't exist and so
you're best off just uh engaging in
raunchy sex acts with presumably food
items of uh either gender
or no gender at all so that is exciting
stuff
the media loved it of course because any
time you make a movie about how heaven
doesn't exist and religious people are
stupid and the solution to this is
raunchy sex the media are into that
message right hedonism is their is their
bag
nigel andrews it's funny nonstop
inventive and heroically heretical yeah
it's super heroic guys nothing says
heroism quite like
taking the same pagan vision that has
been experienced by
cultures across time and does not build
civilizations and then
pushing that on film uh in a format that
is very often sort of
it's an animated film so half directed
to children good stuff there
allison skornick rose for flick direct
sausage party is appallingly offensive
just when you think they can't possibly
go there they go there they insult
everyone and anyone and leave no
stereotype unturned the character's
curse like a bunch of sailors in a
swearing contest
and the food orgy at the end makes you
feel like you're a banana cream pie at a
weight watchers meeting
of course you have to have your moral
compass checked so there's an underlying
message of equality
and make love literally not war it also
needed to bring everyone together to
fight a common enemy and this movie
found it the common enemy of course
being religion so solid stuff i can't
imagine why the audience didn't like it
but the critics did
we're going to jump into the movies that
the audience loved but the critics hated
in just one second first
as part of our daily wire audience you
get to enjoy our content in a bunch of
different ways whether it's through our
app dailywire.com
or over at apple tv and roku if you
haven't downloaded the roku or apple tv
app yet
you definitely will want to do that so
you can enjoy our podcast on your tv as
well as all of our additional content
being added to daily wire that includes
the entire prageru catalog including all
the five minute videos
man on the street with will whit the
book club with michael moles we're also
launching a brand new show with candice
owens next year in front of a live
studio
audience you're going to want to watch
that on your big screen you have to be
an insider member to watch
head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
use code watch and check out
20 off your membership purchase the deal
won't last long
act fast if you want live shows on your
big screen plus one of a kind highly
coveted
never duplicated leftist tears tumblr
again that is dailywire.com
shapiro to get 20 off with code watch
download the daily wire app
on your apple tv and roku today okay now
let's go to one of my childhood
favorites if you grew up in the 90s this
was
a seminal film for you and that of
course was hook right this huge budget
film with robin williams and what's her
name julia roberts maggie smith is in it
and dustin hoffman and the movie's over
long for sure
but it is a watchable flick i watched it
with my kids my kids really enjoyed it
the problem is that it was syrupy sweet
right the the way that
the critics like children's films to be
addressed is taking on deeper issues
deeper issues
and this film basically said it's good
to be a this film does have one of my
favorite scenes in any movie ever
it does have one phenomenal scene so it
has a bunch of scenes like there's one
scene that is just terrific
in which robin williams discovers his
happy thought and his happy thought
after he's had all these terrible things
happen to him throughout his childhood
his happy thought is his kids or his
happy thought is having children which
as a parent like you want to get the
water works going
that happens to be the case
naturally many of the critics didn't
like it not just because they thought it
was over long which is fair
but because they didn't like some of the
the general moral values of it so brian
johnson
from mckellen's magazine wrote a 79
million gallery of a movie scheduled to
sail into north american theaters on
december 11th
hook has everything hollywood currently
holds dear precocious children
regressive adults and an unabashed
nostalgia
for old-fashioned family values
nostalgia for the nuclear family
is everywhere hollywood seems infatuated
with the theme of family harmony well
that would be a terrible thing i mean if
hollywood
the good old days right when hollywood
actually cared about family harmony and
the idea that a kid needed a mom
and a dad and the dad should be involved
and that kids need a father who is
involved
and that fathers need to act with
imagination but also set standards like
very bad stuff
very bad stuff so a lot of the critics
didn't like it of course this is a
beloved film
for a lot of people of my generation
okay so noah
i remember seeing this and being
appalled like as somebody who's a bible
believer and as somebody who takes very
seriously the story of
noah and actually thinks that the text
is quite telling about what exactly
human beings did wrong to uh piss off
god i will say that that noah is a blas
a blasphemous piece of heretical monsons
noah
is made by darren aronofsky perhaps my
least favorite filmmaker of all time i
think darren aronofsky may be the most
overrated filmmaker
of the modern era he's truly bad like i
think he just makes bad films
and not only does he make bad films
they're filled with bad ideas so
this particular film is recasting the
story of noah 76
on tomato meter 41 audience score the
reason for that is because basically
noah turns into
a possibly child murdering barbarian
living among people who are
environmental to spoilers so the problem
in noah is not that the earth is filled
with corruption as it says in the bible
the problem is that human beings are
despoiling the environment they're
mining
right they're doing bad things like
having minds and they're wrecking the
environment which
is not what the story of noah is about
when it says that evil filled the earth
and every man did what was good in his
eyes they're not talking about
environmental desperation
or overpopulation okay that is not what
they are talking about and then it's
filled with all sorts of weird mythical
references that don't make any sense
darren arnofsky has like giant monsters
giant rock monsters that sort of
emerge i remember seeing a screening of
this and being like i don't know what he
is doing right now but i kind of know
what he's doing and that is he's turning
this story
into instead of a referendum on godly
values he's turning it into a referendum
on environmental values and he basically
said that he basically said that he was
obsessed with the story of noah because
it was all about environmental
stewardship which of course
it 100 is not okay finally there's
hillbilly elegy 27 percent of iran
tomatoes 86
audience score and again the big problem
that critics had with this thing
is that it was about people who are
purportedly conservative even though
they are not conservative
and they don't want white working-class
people understood they think that that
is very bad that you should never have a
movie about white working-class people
in fact hollywood has said this right
they say pretty openly that they don't
believe
that movies should be made about males
particularly
who are white and working class it's
just not like the oscars have to have a
certain level of
diversity in your plot in order for
these films to be featured
the film is fine in many ways i think
the film is good has a lot of good
performances i think ron howard strips
out all the politics and the media just
wouldn't let him do it here's the thing
if you want to stand up to the cultural
elite i'm talking about the people who
make these movies i'm talking about the
critics who
criticize these movies and the legacy
media head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe right now if you enjoyed this
hit that thumbs up make sure that you
are subscribed
thank you for tuning in